اكدت مصادر محليه امتداد الاشتباكات بين
مقاتل العشائر العربيه وما تعرف بقوات
السوريه الديمقراطيه الى ريفي الرقه
والحسكه ونفت قيادته عربيه اي هدنه مع
قوات قصد التي اتهمت اطرافنا اجنبيه
بالاستفاده مما وصفته بتاجيج الفتنه بين
الجانبين وبعد اتساع ويعد اتساع رقعه
الاشتباكات تحديا لجهود واشنطن لاحتواء
التصعيد في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه
ما خلفيات واسباب الاشتباكات والتصعيد بين
مقاتل العشائر العربيه وما تعرف بقوه
السوريه الديمقراطيه والتي انطلقت من دير
الزور لكنها توسعت لتشمل مناطق اخرى في
سوريا
ما مدى تاثير هذه التطورات في شرق الفرات
على خارطه التحالفات وموازين القوه في
سوريا كيف ستنعكس ايضا على رؤيه الدول
الفاعله في المشهد السوري لاسيما الولايات
المتحده وروسيا وايران
وهل تنجح واشنطن في احتواء هذا النزاع بين
حلفائها من العشائر العربيه وقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ما ادواتها في ذلك وما
السيناريوهات المحتمله اذا فشلت تلك
المسائل الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
هي مواجهه تحتاج فيما يظهر اكثر من جهود
للتهدئه كي يتم ايقافها واحتواء من جر
عنها من نتائج هكذا بدت الحال فيما يتعلق
بالاشتباكات المتصاعده بين مقاتلي ما يعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ومقاتل العشائر
العربيه في مناطق الشرقي الفرات في الشمال
السوري الولايات المتحده عبرت عن قلقها
البالغ لاندلاع القتال بين الجانبين مؤكده
على متابعتها تطوراته عن كثب داعيه
لانهائه واشنطن ايضا راعت لقاء بين قياده
عربيه واخرى كرديه انتهت الى الاتفاق على
مخاطر التدخلات الاجنبيه في الخلافات
القائمه وضروره تجنب سقوط قتلى وجرحى من
المدنيين والمسارعه الى رفع المظالم التي
يشتكي منها سكان دير الزور
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا
من واشنطن بسام الدبلوماسيه السوريه
السابق وبنتنسلفانيا الدكتور اندرو تابلر
المدير السابق لقسم سوريا في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكيه والمستشار السابق
للمبعوث الامريكيه الخاص الى سوريا وابدا
بضيفنا الاستاذ بسام بربندي بالعوده الى
جذور هذه المشكله سبق وان يعني تجلت حقيقه
هذه المشاكل في مظاهرات عده لاهالي دير
الزور منذ عام 2017
لكن ما هو ما هي النقطه التي يمكن انها او
القشه التي قسمت ظهر البعير كما يقال لكي
تظهر هذه الخلافات الى العالم الان
شكرا للاستضافه والسلام عليكم
مع حضرتك ومع اندرو اندرو صديق قديم وعزيز
وهو ابن احسن ناس الذين يفهمون سوريا
بشكل عقلاني واقعي الخلافات العربيه
الكرديه هي فعلا خلافات قديمه بدات منذ
تاسيس قوات الحمايه للكرديه او
الديمقراطيه للحرب ضد تحرير داعش منطقه
دير الزور هي منطقه عشريه عشائريه قبليه
كبيره عدد سكانها يتجاوز بليون ونصف شخص
فيها كل ابار النفط السوريه فيها الغاز
فيها القطن فيها الماء فيها كل شيء النظام
اول المدن التي قامت ضد النظام النظام ضمن
جزء كبير من المدينه ثم داعش داعش قتلت
اكثر من عشره الاف شخص من المحافظه خلال
تواجدها ثم اجد قوات الامريكيه لطرد داعش
العرب تحالفه مع الامريكان ومع قيادات قصد
قيادات الكرديه
وبعد انتهاء هذه التحرير تبين بان هناك
علاقه
لم لم يكن حياديا والقسد او الاكراد لم
يكنوا ايجابيا بالتعاطي ما حدث مؤخرا بانه
مجلس العسكري لمنطقه دير الزور المعيه
مقاسه وهو مواليد اختلفوا مع قسد على
توزيع عائدات التهريب الذي يقومون به
فسجنوهم المشكله كانت بسجل العائلات
واغتصاب السيدات وقتل الاطفال لهذا هذه
التي فعلا فجرت الموضوع قبليا عشائريا
اخلاقيا لانه اذا لديكم مشكله مع اشخاص
فماذا بالنساء والاطفال ضمن المجتمع
عشائري ضمن التراكمات التي حدثت ضمن عدم
اهتمام الامريكي بحال حقيقي لهذه العلاقه
الغير متوازنه ادى الى ما ادى اليه اليوم
يعني خلال اسبوع واحد تم طرد قوات الكرديه
من اكثر من ثلثي المحافظه
النظام وايران وروسيا يحاولون
زياده وتيره هذه الخلافات يحاولون ارسال
الاشارات الى الاهالي باننا معكم سنعطيكم
سلاح والى اخره ولكن المشكله الحقيقيه
لاهل انهم يرفضون النظام يريدون التعامل
مع
نقطه في غايه الاهميه انه في خلال
الاسابيع
تم الاستيلاء على الثلثي المحافظه من قوات
قصد التي قلت ان قيرتها جاءت من خارج
العراق دعنا نسال هذه التعقيدات كانت
خافيه على الامريكيين حينما كونوا هذا
التحالف
لمحاربه تنظيم الدوله هل يفاجئون الان
بوجود هذه التعقيدات ام انهم ربما يجنون
ويحصدون ما زرعوه من البدايه وهو اغفال
التوازن في هذه العلاقات وهذه التحالفات
اولا اعتقد ان زميلي بسام محق في تحليله
للوضع وهو يعرف هذه المنطقه تماما يعرفها
معرفه جيده تماما هناك بعض الامور ان
القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مهيمن عليها من
قبل الاكراد وايضا من فرع من يتفرع عن حزب
العمال الديمقراطي الذي يحمل
ماركسيه نعم بسام محقم في القول هذه لا
تتناسب مع عادات وتقاليد ومعتقدات السكان
المنطقه ايضا قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لم
تكن راغبه في الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
المصالح القبائل العربيه في شرق الفرات
وهي منطقه تعيش فيها قضاء العربيه وهي
موجوده وبسام في القول انها مستمره منذ
فتره الولايات المتحده تعرف ذلك وهي مشكله
منذ فتره طويله لكن المشكله مع قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه انها كانت ممتعضه
لا ترغبوا في التنازل عن ما حصلت عليه
وايضا في تعاملها مع القضاء العربيه سواء
كانت تعامل خلال المرجس القبائل المدرسه
العسكري في دير الزور او من خلال تغيير
القيادات ابو خوله الى قائد اخر هذا
اثار هذا النزاع وراينا القتال المرير هذا
في الايام الماضيه وهذا يهدد قتال وحرب
امريكا ضد داعش
ويتيح فرصه لايران وروسيا اذا ما استطاعتا
استغلال الموقف لصالحهما ذكر طيران وروسيا
وانا اسال بسام بربندي ايضا قصد اتهمت
يعني قوه خارجيه الولايات المتحده تحدثت
بيان السفاره تحدث عن ايضا عدم السماح
للقوى الخارجيه بالتدخل في هذا في هذا
الصراع ما دور القوى الخارجيه في هذا
الصراع هل هي فقط مستفيده منه ربما تحاول
اغتنامه ام ان لها دورا في اذكائه كذلك
وتفجيره يعني هنا عدد نقاط النقطه الاولى
بان هذه القوه الخارجيه الايراني والروسي
والنظام موجودين في مناطق اسد يعني انت
اسد هي من ادخلتهم خلال الاعظام القليله
الماضيه
تعتقد انهم سيحمون من تركيا
فالحرس الثوري الايراني والقوات الروسيه
موجودين في مطار القامشلي
قريبا جدا من قيادات قصد وتعاونون معها
بشكل يومي فبالتالي بالقول بان النظام هو
يدعم العشائر ضد قصد يعني على ارض المنطق
لا يستوي ولكن هذا لا يخفي بنفس الوقت بان
النظام والروسيا وايران لا يعني
معلنين بشكل علني وبشكل دائم بانهم يريدون
خروج القوات الامريكيه من هذه المنطقه من
سوريا لخيراته الكثيره الاقتصاديه
وبالتالي لديهم مصلحه كبيره بتاجيج النزاع
بتاجيج القتال هم يدركون تماما الخلاف
الكردي العربي او البيكيكي مع المشاعر
العربيه ولكن بنفس الوقت هم يقفلون بانهم
مرفوضون من السكان فبالتالي سيكون اعتقد
هناك اعلام قوي من النظام باننا نحن ندعم
العشائر
ولكن من نفس الوقت العشائر تدرك تماما بان
البديل ليس النظام او اهالي السكان لانه
عشائر يدركون بان البديل ليس النظام
يدركون ان البديل هو التعاون مع الامريكان
ايجاد علاقه متوازنه مع الاكراد
والاستمرار لحياه طبيعيه كما كانت من قبل
اما القول بان الناس ياتون الى نظام
ويجلبون النظام يعني هو كلام فيه كثير من
المبالغات القساديه ضد العرب مره اخرى كل
قواعد النظام والحزب والحرس الثوري
الايراني والقواعد الروسيه هي في مناطق
اسد منذ ثلاثه السنين يوميا يوجد هناك
تنسيق تنسيق مباشر بينهم
نلقي ايضا الضوء على ما تقوله قصت في هذه
في هذه القضيه القياديه الكرديه مثلا
الهام احمد تقول وهي الرئيس التنفيذيه
لمجلس سوريا الديمقراطيه الجناح السياسي
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تقول ان
الاشتباكات الدائره برفي محافظه دير الزور
ليست حوادث معزوله وهناك ادله بتورط
ميليشيات مدعومه من ايران والحكومه
السوريه بالوقوف خلفها الهام شدت ايضا على
ان الهدف من ذلك انما هو اثاره الاضطرابات
وضرب استقرار المنطقه وصرف وانتباه
السوريين عن الحركات الاحتجاجيه في مدينه
السويداء جنوبيه سوريه اندرو تابلر ضيفنا
الاستاذ بربندي يتحدث عن وجود وجود لهذه
القوه لوجود للقوات النظام لقوات الحرس
الثوري في هذه المناطق مناطق اسد منذ ثلاث
سنوات هل القول بانها سبب هذه الاشتباكات
الان
يعني اجانبه الدقه ام هو قول دقيق
القوات الايرانيه والقوات النظام
الجانب الجنوبي من الفرات هناك تجمع كبير
للميليشيات الايرانيه وهي طلقه
مساعدات ودعما من القوات نظام الاسد
واحيانا القوات الروسيه والى شمال شرق
النهر
النفوظ التركي وقوى سور الديمقراطيه
ومجلس دير الزور العسكري ايضا السيطره
هناك ما يقوله بسام هو ان النظام
الايرانيين لم يحاول سقط التواصل مع
القبائل العربيه لتحريضهم على الانضمام
الى تحالفهم
فقط
وذلك
ليسوروا وينتفضوا ضد الولايات المتحده وح
الديمقراطيه فقط
وبيحاولون استغلال هذه المشكله الموجوده
من قبل من قبل
بين القياده الكرديه لقصاد
والقضاء العربيه
اذا
هاتانمكيتان تغذيان بعضهما البعض والقوات
الامريكيه طبعا موجوده في هذه المنطقه
بشكل اساسي في منطقه الشرق سوريا الامنيه
وهي المنطقه التي تشهد هذه الانتفاضات
وهذا القتال اذا الموقف متشنت
ومعقد المتحده تحاول تهدئه الموقف وسنرى
كيف ستتعامل هي وقوات قصد مع الموقف
وبرايك السيد
ما هي اوراق الولايات المتحده في تهدئه
هذا الموقف
ان هناك عددا من الاوراق احدى هذه الاوراق
هو العمل مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
المدى البعير لكي تقدم تنازلات
للقبائل والاعشائر العربيه وايضا قاده
القاده العرب في المجلس العسكري
للتعامل مع مظالمهم طبعا هذا صعب لقوات
قصد لان الطريقه التي يحكمون بها هذه
المناطق والطريقه التي ينظمون بها الامور
وهيكليتهم
التنظيميه الولايات المتحده ايضا يمكن
ايضا ان تتصدى لمحاولاتها الايرانيين
ومحاولاتي النظام من خلال مساعده
العناصر القبليه المشكله هو ان من الناحيه
التاريخ
قوات قصد لا تريد رؤيته المتحده ان تعمل
باستقلاليه مع العشائر العربي تريد
الولايات المتحده ان تبقى في صفها على طول
الطريق اعتقد ان الفريق الدبلوماسي
الامريكي الموجود الان في سوريا
يحاول تقييم الاوضاع وربما قد نرى بعض
البيانات المفصله وايضا
وايضا محاولات من قوات قصد لاستعاده بعض
القرى التي خسرتها واستعاده السيطره ليس
عن طريق القتال بل عن طريق التفاهم ربما
هذا هذا الشبكات وهذا الصراع استاذ بربندي
كما تفضلت تفضل ضيفنا يعني في منطقه
بها وجود
وتشابك دولي كبير تركيا من جانب الولايات
المتحده روسيا ايران
كيف تنظر كل هذه الاطراف الى ما يجري
الجزيره السوريه منطقه الحسكه هي اقرب
نقطه عسكريه يتواجد فيها الجيش الامريكي
مع الجيش الروسي المسافه بينهم خمسه كيلو
متر اكبر قاعده امريكيه مع اكبر قاعده
روسيه او اكبر من الاحداث اكبر القواعد
الروسيه في سوريا يبعد البعد بينهم فعلا
خمسه كيلو متر الموضوع جدا يعني
خطير بين نادي اذا اخذناها دوليا موضوع
جدا خطير مره اخرى روسيا ايران النظام لا
يخفون مطالبهم اليوميه بضروره خروج القوات
الامريكيه من سوريا قسى تتعامل مع النظام
تزور لنظام تحاول ان تحصل على حكم ذاتي من
النظام بدعم امريكي او بغطاء امريكي
ايران تنظر الى قصب امتداد
فبالتالي يرفضون هذه الطلبات الولايات
المتحده يعني تريد البقاء في هذه الارض هي
الدوله العظمى تستطيع فرض بقائها ولكن اذا
لم يكن هناك
حاميه شعبيه الوجود الوجود سيكون محدود
لفتره زمنيه محدوده النقطه التي اريد
الجواب على حضرتك فيها ما هي اوراق القوه
التي الولايات المتحده كل سكان المنطقه من
عرب واكراد اسلام ومسيحيين اكراد سوريين
سوريان منطقه غنيه بالكره التنوع الثقافي
والديني هم لا يرون دليلا عن الولايات
المتحده لا احد يرغب بايران او روسيا او
النظام ابدا هم يريدون بقاء الولايات
المتحده وهذا يعطي الولايات المتحده قوه
معنويه كبيره لفرض حال يرضي الجميع اذا هي
ارادت ان تقوم بهذا الحل هي حاليا كما
تفضل اندرو اكثر ميلا الى مطالب الاكراد
البيانات التي اصدروها منذ امس اليوم سنه
بيانات للاسف هي غير غير جيده لا تناسب
الواقع
تجاري اكثر بيانات
الموضوع ليس ليس فعلا ليس له علاقه
يعني هذا هذا الاجماع كما تفضلت وكما تقول
على انه لا بديل عن الامريكان ومع ذلك رغم
المسائل الامريكيه الاشتباكات تتصاعد بل
وتتسع ركعاتها وتصل الى مناطق اخرى
الممثلين لهذا التجمع الخليط من العشاء لا
يوجد شخص او شخصين يجب ان يدعو على الاقل
30 شخص ليسمعوا منهم الحقيقه هم التقوا
للاسف مع اشخاص اقرب الى اسد منهم الى
العرب عنهم عرب وبالتالي اصدروا البيان
الذي هو اقرب الى قصه من العرب وبالتالي
هذا يفيد ايران وروسيا ونظام مره اخرى
يحاول التواصل مع الاميركان نقول لهم يجب
ان يكون هناك اكثر توازن اكثر حكمه
بالتعاطي لهذا الامر لانه كما تفضل كما
يعرف الجميع اي فرائض امريكي سيمتلئ بقوى
معادله لامريكا معادي حتى للشعب السوري
ككل بالمجمل يعني مصلحه الجميع هي ايجاد
حل لهذه الظروف وهو حل عادل اعطاء العرب
حقوقهم الاداريه الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه
الثقافيه يعني منطقه كلها عشائر فيها طبع
من العلاقات الاجتماعيه
هل هذا يمثل الاولويه لدى الامريكيين اريد
ان اسال الاندرو تابلور الى اي مدى
الولايات المتحده معنيه بما يطرحه الاستاذ
بربندي من احداث توازن من النظر الى
المطالب والمظالم العربيه التعامل مع
الموضوع على انه مجموعه مظالم ينبغي
التعامل معها ام تهدئه
لتبقى الامور كما هي عليه وان يستمر الامر
الواقعيا مكان شكله واي مكان التناقضاته
المتحده تريد شيئا ناجعا ناجحا عمليا هي
لا تريد الرحيل عن سوريا وتعرف ان قوى
وايضا نظام قد تسيطر عليها وان داعش قد
يستعيد قوته تقوم به المتحده في الايام
المقبله سنعرف ما هو ولكن هو في كل حالات
هو دليل على التوتر بين قياده قصد التي
يهن عليها الاكراد وبين القوى القبائل
والعشائر العربيه الشرق هي مشكلات يمكن
حلها بسهوله ببعض انماط التفكير العملي
لانه كما قال بسام القضاء لا تريد عوده
النظام بعضهم لديه علاقات وثيقه معهم لكن
لديهم مظالم مع قوات قصد نامل في حلها وان
يعودوا الامر الى استطاعه للعمل سويا ماذا
لو لم يحدث ذلك ماذا لو كان هذه كانت هذه
القراءه خاطئه وان الامر اكثر تعقيدا مما
يظن الامريكيون مثلا
[موسيقى]
المدير السابق لقسم سوريا في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي والمستشار السابق للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاص الى سوريا الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر في
امان الله
[موسيقى]